he's saying my kingdom is made up of
people
it's done without hands which means no
human intervention it's not legalism at
all
right but it's going to result in a
change start in which the ten
commandments are there
that harmonizes all these competing
ideas that people get so mixed up on
it's all him wow that's deep that's
beautiful
hey everybody welcome to led live is it
a scary thing to think about
standing in judgment before the king of
the universe
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
so welcome back everybody this is part
of a series we have our guest
scott burgess with us he's blessed us
with the topic
of marriage and to see the connection in
revelation so welcome back on our show
good to be here and we're gonna get back
into this topic a little bit here
um this one is titled the stand what
does that mean
uh one of the key ideas in the book of
daniel
which is the companion to revelation is
standing in
the judgment that word appears
throughout the book every story has it
i i think that's kind of make me sweat a
little bit
but if we remember that the judgment is
the wedding that's really about standing
for our wedding that's right that's
right that's awesome so i'm excited to
hear these connections and these
parallels with this one as well
so the question is would you be scared
if you had to go to court and your wife
was the judge hopefully not yes i would
all right she knows all the secrets yeah
okay well let's let's uh let's jump in
here uh just do a
quick review of daniel chapter two in
daniel chapter two
the king has a dream and in it
he sees well first of all he cannot
recall the dream but he
he knows it's important so he he wants
to find out what is the dream and what
does it mean
so he calls for daniel and
daniel tells him that there is a god in
heaven that reveals secrets
and he makes known to king
nebuchadnezzar what shall be in the
latter days
so i know this much has something to do
with the latter days
but he also um we don't know
what in the latter days
however in verse 30 of the same chapter
not only does he say it's in the latter
days but he says it has to do with the
thoughts of your heart
so the king is thinking about how is my
kingdom gonna prosper is it gonna
is it gonna continue it's my name you
know we talk about a legacy these days
that's that's essentially what he's
thinking about right there so he's
focused on what's gonna happen
in the future for this kingdom now
our focus is not on the whole dream but
just
just so we have something to set the
stage he sees this metal image and on
the metal image it has a head of gold
and he's told that represents you okay
your kingdom battle
then he keeps working his way down the
image he has the silver torso that's
meadow persia
we have brass for the the
thighs the upper legs and then the lower
legs are iron and that is
rope now
uh what's interesting though is why did
god
choose these particular metals and it's
interesting if you look in second
chronicles chapter two
we learned something that may not be
obvious to everybody second chronicles
chapter 2 verses 6
through 8. this is when
david has been given the plans
to build a house for the lord but he's
told you can't do it
your son will do it but in those verses
it turns out we find these very metals
it says here that the rulers of the
king's work offered willingly
and gave for the service of the house of
god gold a certain amount
silver a certain amount brass and even
says iron
you may not have known iron was in the
sanctuary but it was and also
it says that there were precious stones
that were used as well
so that tells us that right now it's no
accident you use these metals
for the image it actually is a very
subtle
but it is a hint a subtle hint that this
dream has something to do with sanctuary
that's interesting i always thought the
medals were a direct link to the kingdom
because that's what
was prevalent during that time god has
i don't know how he does it but he has
his sovereignty i guess but those
kingdoms yes i mean like if you look at
the coinage that they used
or the weapons each of these metals in
fact
was characteristic of those kingdoms
yeah
god somehow knew that and that was true
but
also he says they have another
significance
instead of earthly kingdoms they have
something to do with the way he runs
so they're both there so that's
absolutely true it's so multi-layered i
just love how god does that it's like he
he kind of has these just things
underneath the surface and keep going
and it's like
i think that's why when we study the
bible in heaven's
future we will forever be blown away
like oh this is crazy look at this
parallel you know and be sharing back
and forth so this is something mikey
showed me because
it's similar in hosea 13 because
in daniel 7
you also have the different beasts right
so in hosea 13 starting in verse 7
it says so i will be to them this is god
speaking
like a lion like a leopard by the road i
will lurk i will meet them like a
bear deprived of her cubs i will tear
open their rib cage
and there i will devour them like a lion
the wild beast
shall tear them out yeah
four beasts there that are the same as
they are in daniel chapter seven which
is fascinating
again god is using them to describe his
characteristics but they're also used
for
earthly kingdom we should have wore our
four beasts sure
i can't wait for a bible study with
jesus man
absolutely anyway let me be crazy did
you notice this yeah he actually sits
down and goes yeah yeah
you know when when you look at this part
look at it over here yeah it'd be wild
it's amazing because we have trouble
just connecting
things in a line but god has he can
he can have so many different things
come together and merge and we think
that's how could anyone do that yeah
okay yeah and again we're not gone
it's like it's like the prediction um or
i guess you wouldn't call it a
prediction but
um the prophecies of jesus coming about
right it wasn't just one it wasn't just
two it was like
thousands wasn't it i mean the
likelihood of those
those probabilities coming together is
just i think i remember seeing
it was like one with like 17 zeros after
it or something it was just insane
there's no way it could happen by chance
that's right
all right so the king's dream in order
to understand it properly
we've got to have in view that temple
was built solomon's temple
and that is in fact that was a model of
god's heavenly table so with that
mindset then we can go ahead
and see what the lesson is for today
there were those four medals in this on
the that came uh
in the image but then it also said there
was a stone that hit it
and remember we mentioned something
about stones there and that list in
sacramento
our focus is going to be on this stone
right here
so when daniel goes on in verses 34 and
35 of daniel 2
he says talking to the king you saw till
that a
stone was cut out without hands which
struck the image upon its feet that were
of iron and clay and broke them into
pieces
then was the iron the clay the brass the
silver and the gold broke into pieces
together
and the stone that smote the image
became a great mountain
to fill the whole earth so there it's
not just the
image the stone that does away with the
image or something that's very
significant about that but
what yeah so that's the intriguing thing
we want to explore that a little bit
so what does the stone represent
a lot of times if you ask people if
they're christians anyways
they'll say the stone represents what
jesus kingdom
now just pretend that you're go back to
your pre-christian days and you don't
already know christian lingo and certain
symbols and everything
can you see how somebody might scratch
your head and say wait a minute there's
a there's this rock that hit
an image and you're telling me it's
jesus it doesn't say it's a person
what i mean what's the connection there
so what we need to do first is
i agree that jesus is the rock of ages
but if we just let the text explain
itself
in daniel's explanation down in verse 44
of the same chapter
he's explaining each of the metals and
then right where he needs to talk about
the stone he says god will establish a
kingdom which will not be strong
[Music]
now we'll explore the connection between
king and the kingdom but right now
yeah the primary thing that's in view is
that the stone is actually god's kingdom
that's the focus
now a good question is if we had a
statue an image that was all of metals
why does god change it when he talks
about his own kingdom why did he switch
it and now it's a stone
why didn't you just come up with some
new metal just to kind of keep that same
motif going i like how it's set apart
like nothing you've ever seen nothing
that was ever established before
it's like this external thing that comes
and changes everything
right it does it does make a distinction
anyways i mean because you have
one type of material versus four others
so right there there's at least a
difference but
if we could establish more precisely why
you don't
really any of the other materials to
build a foundation
hmm okay that's actually interesting
because if you look at the foundations
of the holy city
or at least the wall in the city it says
that those are all various like
precious stuff that's exactly right yeah
but yeah you don't you don't build a
foundation on gold you don't build one
in silver you don't want to build one of
bronze
you don't really build a foundation with
iron you might use it for the structural
part but you don't build a foundation
with that
you know the bible says a wise man built
his house upon a rock that was the
foundation
that's going to keep you stable that
much is true
okay well um all right so looking at the
question why is it represented as a
stone
to understand it let's just go to the
scriptures and see if there's some clues
right there
and one i think is a very handy place to
look at is in ezekiel chapter 28 so let
me let me take a look over here in
ezekiel 28
and this gives us a little bit of
history here before this world existed
it tells us how things were in heaven
right there
and before we look at that just bear in
mind daniel 235
just remind yourself it was a stone
smoke the image and it says it became a
great
mountain we're gonna find those two key
words here in ezekiel 28
and yeah we'll look here at verses 14
through 16.
so i don't know um candy did you want to
read those sure
ezekiel 28 verses 14 through 16
you are the anointed cherub that covers
and i have set
you so you were upon the holy mountain
of god you have walked up and down in
the midst of the stones of fire
you were perfect in your ways from the
day that you were created
till iniquity was found in you by the
multitude of your merchandise
they have filled the midst of you with
violence
and you have sinned therefore i will
cast you as profane
out of the mountain of god and i will
destroy you o covering cherub
from the midst of the stones of fire
okay so you notice right there we have
we have stones as well as uh mountain
and i don't think that is a that's a
coincidence i think this is actually to
inform our understanding because
we have a stone that strikes a metal
image and it does mention that it has
something to do with a mountain and
you know when does a stone become a
mountain but here it's very plain that
well there's a mountain
god has that's characterized by these
stones of fire so it sounds like maybe
maybe this has something to do with it
um
one thought i came across i there's a an
old article i read here
it's in a publication was called review
and herald and this
interesting statement was made it says
that the vacancies that were made in
heaven by the fall
of satan and his angels will be filled
by the redeemed of the lord the
vacancies that were
you know satan and the angels that
walked among these stones of fire
on the mountain they were cast out so
now there is an emptiness
so now god's going to fill it with his
people
and so yeah we're privileged to occupy
the very vacancies that were left there
on god's mountain among the fiery stones
i think it's fairly interesting when you
when you look at
how the bible describes fire and the
things that are associated with that
fire
and yet in much of christendom
um it's it's like a fearful thing like
fire is hell and this and that but yet
when you really look at it like
you know jesus is on fire his feet are
on fire as eyes ball
look like they're on fire we will walk
amongst the
fiery stones you know and and so you
know i could see how the devil just
takes that concept
and flips it upside down on its head and
makes it a fearful thing
rather than how the bible describes it
the destruction of the destruction
by fire comes out of heaven right in the
end times it says that he'll bring
fire from god out of heaven and destroy
the wicked and yeah same thing with like
sodom and gomorrah and stuff
it fell from heaven but it's almost like
also if you stood in the presence of god
you would
immediately burn up because of our
sinfulness right but
if we are translated to heaven and
um you know given new bodies and and we
no longer have that sin a part of us
you can stand in the presence of god and
you will not burn up so
that fire coming from heaven really is
consuming
because of the sinful nature of those
that are
in front of it it's interesting because
it actually asks a question in the bible
in isaiah i think it's chapter 33
and it says who can dwell with the
everlasting burnings
it's not the wicked but the popular
conception of an eternal place of
torment
rather it says it's those who have clean
hands it's the righteous
that's right and the angels that are
right there like the the word seraphim
in the bible
it means the burning ones oh they're in
god's presence but they're not being
consumed they're free of sin they're
there
so describe that why why is it called
the the
fiery ones well i mean because god
himself is a consuming fire right right
yeah
and those who are in his immediate
presence they're going to be just
in the versions of fire yeah interesting
so they are burning yeah i wonder if
shadrach meshach and
like i can abednego them worthy to stand
in fire
right kind of a glimpse of what's to
come yeah yeah
yeah because it says when they came out
there wasn't even the smell of smoke
yeah i mean you can't go to your
fireplace with a little puny fire right
you're gonna at least have smoke in your
hands and if it's a big one you're gonna
have smoke all over you
nebuchadnezzar was convinced what's
fascinating to me though
too is so if you can't
you you can't stand in the presence of
god without being pure
without being consumed because if you
hold on to your sin you're to be
consumed with your sin
and yet it's fire that also purifies us
right and burns it up so yeah it burns
it off so it's it's
it's almost like well what's what's the
difference i think the difference is
whether you're holding on or letting go
you know
if you're holding on you're consumed
with
the same if you let go and say yes
purify me then god burns that away and
then
you're pure and as pure and you know
only by his grace
you're able to stand mm-hmm good point i
think paul says you know
this fire will try everything to see
what sword it is
if it's a wood hay and stuff yeah it
gets burned up but
if it's uh like say stone that will last
it speaks to how small-minded we can be
if we read the bible
with our own eyes and our own worldview
that's why it's so important to pray
before you read have the holy spirit
guide you
and be intentional as you read you know
look at those key words and things like
that
have you guys ever seen colored fire
people yeah
it's incredible what do you mean where
they actually add some different
chemicals to it you'd probably know
you actually it's what they do with
fireworks you you add different
metals and different metals will burn
different colors
so for example if you want that blue
green look you're going to put some kind
of copper
you know compound in or iron is going to
be more of your like brownish
brownish reds it kind of changed my
whole view of not only god but heaven
heaven is a colorful beautiful place so
i'm actually not picturing red
everywhere you know or things like
breaking apart
it's probably really colorful in
different colors of fire
probably i don't know i guess we'll find
out is there any connection here where
the the 10 commandments were written in
stone
and it puts them in your heart i think
you're jumping ahead i think i know
exactly where he's going with this
is that i think there's a connection
here i think
i think i think i know where he's going
all right
okay well so getting back to this right
here yeah
the there's vacancies on god's mountain
along the very stones
and we are going to become a stone
kingdom
that is cut out of that very mountain so
we're going to fill the vacancy there
okay and the kingdom is going to stand
forever you know stone is fitting right
stone
a diamond is forever that's right there
you go okay
it says okay
now that stone though it's cut out of
god's not in heaven so here's a question
what is god's mountain
can you identify it is there a
particular mountain
sion cyanide
well santa is on earth yeah yeah yeah
but zion
yeah psalm 48 is one place it talks
about mount zion on the sides of the
north is the city of the great king
that is his mountain that's right
but there is another mountain that's
called god's mountain and you already
got it
yeah sinai yep if you uh so zion mount
zion is in heaven
forever yeah exodus 3 1
uh as the book of exodus opens it talks
about once moses has become a shepherd
he slept from pharaoh
it says that he came to the mountain of
god horeb
but that's the same thing as sinai so
there's a connection between those two
mountains there
now what's the main thing that happened
at mount sinai what do we think of the
10th commandment forgiveness
ten commandments that's right god spoke
all these words and then the ten
commandments follow
and of course the obvious question what
were the ten commandments written on
sapphire's stone they're written on
stone that's right
sapphire right well we'll see fire the
word fires in their fire
okay yeah yeah
after god had given the ten commandments
he told moses come up to me into the
mount
i will give you tables of stone and the
law
and commandments which i have written
okay
but that's verse 12. the interesting
question to explore is yeah
where did the stone tablets come from i
mean did god just sort of reach down and
say oh here's
here's a rock over here i'll just you
know i
moses brought the stones right the first
time i know he brought him the second
time
second time second time so he did not
bring him the first time correct
okay so i i always wondered that when he
breaks them
the first time right and then all of a
sudden it's like hey i need some huge
stones you know like where did he get
them from i mean it's not just
simply laying around no what about i'm
looking at
exodus 34 4 it says and he hewn two
tables of stone like under the first and
moses rose up early in the morning
and went up unto mount sinai as the lord
had commanded him and he took in his
hands
the two tables of stone the second time
after moses
moses had to bring them god still wrote
with his finger on the second set
says in deuteronomy but on the first set
god provided the stone
and he wrote on it see they got that
wrong in that exodus movie
that's right they said moses brought the
stones hollywood is not a good source to
go for uh
biblical yeah i know yeah so where did
the stone tables come from
heaven the bible actually the bible
actually tells us i mean yeah how
interesting the immediate context yeah
so it sounds like you probably have an
idea there yeah i actually
preached a sermon like years ago early
in my
mid-20s called stones of fire okay and
i think it's pretty easily provable
between ezekiel
and exodus what the stones are yeah
that's exactly right if you go back two
verses here in exodus 24
it mentions something and it's it can't
mean anything except
exactly what it says it says the people
saw the god of israel and there was
under his feet as it were a paved work
of
sapphire stone and is it where the body
of heaven and his clearness
now it corrects me if i'm wrong but in
in jewish culture when they would
actually add a hymn of blue around the
base of the
of the priest's garment it was really to
signify
the the law right being you know
interwoven into the very fabric of their
of the priest's outfit and just to make
the connection yeah
sapphire generally blue so yes yeah what
are the other colors
purple and scarlet gold like that's the
in revelation it talks about this false
church that has
all the colors but blue the lawless one
so they
look like the church but they're missing
the blue actually it's very interesting
revelation
17 there yeah that she's dressed as a
high priest
purple scarlet and scarlett being
pressured she's not she's missing white
no purity she's missing the
the blue for the face which would
ultimately leave you with red
well purple and purple scarlet and gold
and precious stones all that stuff
just like his outfit now i don't know if
you're going to go over this but um
you know ezekiel when it talks about um
giving him
all the precious stones it's speaking of
lucifer right so it's talking about
um covering him with the stones and he
had the stones that are mentioned
on the priest's outfit as well but he's
missing a few of them
yeah he was he was similar the best i
can
understand it since he was the highest
creative being it seems like perhaps he
was a
maybe you could say like the right-hand
man while he was faithful
to the high priest but he was not the
high priest and it was similar but not
identical yeah that's right
well so he's apparently he's gotten
those sapphire stones there
but now this is the question here he's
written them on sapphire stone
but where do you get sapphire stone from
because i mean if mountains had sapphire
on them
all the robbers in the world long ago
would have figured that out and rounded
up all the sapphire right
so where did god find sapphire did he
just happen to find
oh sign is a good mountain because it
has sapphire on it so in his mountain
yeah wasn't it underneath his throne or
as proceeding out of the throne was a
look like a a pathway of sapphire stone
oh i see okay well it sounded like you
were yeah i was gonna say
there is that connection in in ezekiel
i mean it's it's i think some of this is
about perspective
you know um the people are given the
perspective from the ground
looking up right so when you go back to
that verse it was
do you have it exodus 24 24 10 and they
saw the god of israel and there was
under his feet so they're they're
looking up and they're saying what's
under god's feet
it's not necessarily that they're
looking at the mountain right
yes god is on the mountain but they're
not looking it's not that the mountain
itself
has is made of sapphire like he's saying
so they're looking up
you get a similar perspective from
ezekiel yeah
yeah that's that's right and there's
also there's an assumption a lot of
people make here too
but yeah in ezekiel ezekiel chapter 1
verse 26 ezekiel at the beginning of his
book he gets a glimpse
of jesus and he says he refers he says
that he sees this likeness of a throne
as the appearance of a sapphire stone
that's where you have that exact same
phrase used again
and that's the only place you're going
to find it so it's evident that ah
it actually comes from god's throne
that's where it gets it from it didn't
say when i said it's under his feet
did it say that god was standing on the
mountain
i didn't say that but it did say it's
under his feet
how could it be on his feet on the
mountain and he's not standing
what's the other sitting on the mountain
he's sitting on the
throne yeah it's like his footstool yes
that's exactly what it is
and it makes sense because then you
think oh he gave the ten commandments
the basis of judgment wouldn't he be
seated as
he would one day as the final judge okay
interesting universe yeah so that's
where the stone comes from right there
so what we want to know at this point is
that the ten commandments are written on
sapphire stone
from the from the foundation of his
throne but it says in the bible that the
foundation of his throne
is righteousness and judgment it's true
in a literal way it's like
at the base of the throne there is
literally the ten commandments
so it's it's true literally as well as
the figure feet
mercy and grace well that's true they
meet there
yeah that's right yep
okay oh there it is right psalm 97 verse
2 righteousness and judgment are the
foundation
of your throne yeah so it's not just a
figure speech it is actually
literally true and in the in the
sanctuary
like the mosaic one they'd have the ark
the mercy seats on top
that's where the you know god's presence
would be and then within it
was the ten commandments and so that's
the foundation yeah that's where his
feet would rest as it were
so it's interesting how god is so
literal but like figurative or like so
metaphoric but yet so practical you know
what i mean
exactly i mean because he can use things
and we might just read it like the first
time somebody read the bible they'd read
a statement like psalm 97 verse 2 and
they're just saying okay
it's just telling me that he's got a
government that's just and right just
that makes sense
but then i guess god knows that we're so
we're easily confused
he says but don't miss what it literally
says it's just literally true and when
we get there we'll say oh
yeah it really is just exactly like that
i i
i am and i think a lot of people are
visual people
so it's almost like a monument to wreck
to recognize every time you see it oh
yeah his
his foundation is based on his law and
all this stuff
right so what we set up here is that
yeah the ten commandments are the
foundation of his kingdom
okay um if we consider also what the
bible says more about the ten
commandments in exodus 34
28 this one tells us that they are in
fact
the words of the covenant which is
marriage language
that's exactly right we talked about
that in the last the last episode that
we did with you
um yeah i mean this is this is this is
the marriage language the covenant
is that that relationship and the
document the covenant i mean the bible
is also spoken to as the covenant
and interesting when it's written in
stone that
indicates that it's forever but if it's
the basis of his marriage covenant then
he says
my marriage is forever here are the
terms if you agree to that you let me
change you into it
it's going to be this way for eternity
so
40 days and 40 nights again as well
yeah it talks about god who keeps
covenant and mercy with them that
love him because it is a marriage
relationship right there
uh we referred to malachi chapter two in
our last talk
that yeah god he hates divorce because
he wants
permanent marriage okay so yes the ten
commandments those are the basis of his
marriage covenant
so we think of the law sometimes is like
this it doesn't seem pleasant you know
you better do this
and if not there's punishment but we're
looking at the wrong way
i'm sure there are consequences but god
says you don't have to have those if
you're willing to marry me
i i have a tendency to speed in my car
all the time
um if a car just had two speeds go and
stop i'd be happy right
and um i don't know why but it's
it is difficult for me to like you know
want to drive 35 miles an hour through
the
through the town right to me that just
seems like so slow i can't do it right
i saw sign the other day that said drive
as
if your kids were in our neighborhood
yeah
and and it was really interesting
because i have kids
and all of a sudden it changed the
context of that and i think the same
thing is true to the
ten commandments you can look at them
like don't do this don't do that don't
do this don't do that
or you can look at them like you know
what i wouldn't
cheat on my bride i wouldn't lie to her
i wouldn't steal from her or anything
like this and it changes the context of
how we
actually have a relationship with those
ten commandments and
stop looking at them as this fearful
thing but as a
as a as a beautiful thing what about if
the ten commandments is
now on the cross and we cannot keep
anymore so we under grace
then there is there is no marriage
covenant
and by the way that when that what
people talk about that were they're
using grace in the sense of mercy
grace in the bible is the ability god
gives to keep it
if we're saying that he's done away with
it it's like saying that we can't keep
it that's not grace
so when you say mercy and grace a lot of
times people think it's basically saying
mercy and mercy
yeah but it's really useful they're two
different things and
yeah yeah that's right
back to what you were saying scotty it
takes you back to that golden rule
treat others as you would be treated so
do you want to be cheated on
do you want people to steal from you
mm-hmm there you go
don't do it to other people
yeah a it's an excellent way to look at
things yep okay so now what is on god's
mountain
well it turns out there's many places we
identify that god's sanctuary is right
there
psalm 20 says send help from the
sanctuary strengthen you out of
mount zion so the sanctuary is right
there
uh we saw earlier in ezekiel 28 that yes
there are stones of
fire there in the holy mountain maybe
there's stones of fire in god's
sanctuary yeah we know that the
the foundation's the wall around the
city has those stones that are
uh very similar to the ones a little bit
different arrangement but the ones on
the high priest breast plate and
everything
yeah you know in ezekiel 28 um verse 14
it talks about once again that that that
that section that's talking about
lucifer it says you are the anointed
cherub that covereth
right and you think of the ten
commandments is inside of the ark with
the two cherub
over that protecting the law of god i
mean that was what lucifer's job was in
heaven was he was the protector or the
the let me tell you what god's character
is really like and that's why when he
went to everybody else
in the universe and went you know what
god's really not like that in fact
he's kind of this mean guy you're gonna
believe the guy that that's his job to
tell you how he
is you know and so that's why he was
able to be so effective with winning so
many people over to his side
what if the arc of the covenant just has
one cherub on it now
yeah someone took his place right
probably right
uh michael well michael was jesus
it would be um gabriel gabriel gabriel
yes
right yeah he was yeah he's on the that
mercy seat it's
the atonement cover is the best
translation right there so if you're a
covering chair that means you're right
there on the atonement cover
at one point lucifer was at one with god
and how sad that the very closest of all
the beings in the universe
by the way he chose not to remain
surrendered
i wonder if judas was kind of like a
parallel of lucifer or something you
know
he was right there with jesus all the
time oh yeah totally turned on
uh what is going on in the heavenly
sanctuary in the latter days
what's taking place he is jesus is
interceding for us
okay he's a high priest like we talked
about in the wedding
he's been in your seating ever since he
went to heaven you know
right after you know 40 days or 40 days
after his um
resurrection but then a special work
goes on in the very you know end of time
where it moves to that work of of
judgment
and so we have that going on right there
though the day of atonement or the
judgment that's true
daniel 8 14 tells us when that started
you can actually
you can narrow that down to a to a date
right there
but in leviticus 16 it goes over the
whole process of how god
cleanses the sanctuary and that's that's
the day of atonement right there
we saw in matthew 22 that the wedding
which is the same thing as the day of
atonement it's an investigation so it's
a judgment
uh the parable of the ten virgins again
wedding and judgment go
hand in hand right there what you can
conclude though is really interesting
if the judgment is taking place in that
in that heavenly sanctuary
in the holy apologies right there it's
the wedding chamber
it's where it goes it's where the vowels
are exchanged
and it's like that inner apartment it's
the it's the
i mean i guess you could say just to use
the words we understand it's like the
bedroom
it's the most intimate place i remember
hearing a sermon from dwayne lemon one
time
that he talked about these parallels
between the high priest
and um the man in the marriage and like
you know the only one that's allowed to
see
within the inner veil you know is the is
the high priest the male figure
um and i just was like wow that's crazy
that even on a physical level whether
you believe in god or not it's like we
we are playing these many little roles
that illustrate these deeper spiritual
truths
because even an atheist wants his wife
to be just for him
that's right that's right it's it's like
how god witnesses through nature you
know
through things that we experience every
day
and if that atheist ever opened their
heart to god god gets
could use that as an illustration you
know how you love your wife you know you
only want her to be with you
that's how i am you know but the
sanctuary being that
intimate connection that we're able to
have with god right like
like our bodies are like the sanctuary
right we have the shekinah glory where
he is
supposed to be dwelling we have the like
sort of the most holy place
even in this illustration of the human
body
and so it's it's this is interesting
yeah
yeah and we mentioned in our our last
time that the final judgment being the
wedding it is
at one minute atonement is at one minute
but like one flesh
so really all these things come together
it makes a lot of sense
um we pointed out before what is the
basis
of the judgment what is god's standard
ten commandments
ten commandments right and he judges our
lives to see are they in harmony are
they not in harmony with it
and the verse is right there in the last
two verses of zeke uh
ecclesiastes it talks about that we are
to keep his commandments that's the
whole conclusion the whole matter
and he's going to bring every work into
judgment we're to keep
the marriage covenant because that's
what he's evaluating right now in the
courtship
so the ten commandments they're written
in stone showing us that the marriage
contract is permanent
you know that you've got the the stone
it hits that image right there
the image shatters because none of the
earthly kingdoms however they've
gotten themselves into power it's all by
man's methods and so nothing lasts
but he says you've got to have a
foundation if you've got this foundation
the ten commandments
my character that's the one that's gonna
last forever and it's interesting that
he strikes it on the feet
because that is its foundation he says
that's clay and r that's got to go
but this is just okay now obvious
question who is the judge during the
judgment
jesus jesus that's exactly right what we
can learn about
jesus we've seen that he's the son of
man and we learned that oh the son of
man
it's also the bridegroom so we know that
much
but in the day of atonement
he's the high priest and if you look at
how the high priest if you look at his
outfit which is
ornamented notice how it's described
in exodus 28 he's got two onyx stones on
his shoulders
bible also says that he has this breast
piece right here
and he has 12 stones right there four
rows of three each and he also has the
urem and the thume right there
so he's got all these stones right there
and that's fascinating so like the bible
yeah the government is on his shoulder
isaiah 9 verse 6.
and and weren't the stones kind of a
representation of the tribes of israel
as well
that they were actually on his heart and
this is why it was on the breastplate
that is exactly right it's interesting
because the bible says that he is going
to give us a new name
it's like he's got the names recorded
right there but he's going to give us a
name and yeah he's got the names
on his heart yeah so which is like a
you know you just think you see this
relationship through and through and
through
you know when you're when you're falling
in love with somebody you know you write
little things
to them you you have them constantly on
your mind on your heart
it's like everything you do is a
remembrance you know you
you have articles and things that that
make you just think of that person
so yeah yeah it shows the intimacy right
there it's
he has the names written here and he has
the names written right here but it does
show that union right there on the heart
yep this is what's really fabulous
the names are on those stones which kind
of suggests that
god regards his people like it's some
sort of stone but peter is very explicit
in first peter 2
he says that we are to come to him as a
living stone
and he lays in zion a chief cornerstone
who is the stone right here so
the stone can represent jesus kingdom as
you said earlier
but also the king himself that's
consistent because daniel 2 talks about
kings and kingdoms are interchangeable
so if his kingdom's a stone kingdom it
makes sense that he is the stone
king also dana said to nebuchadnezzar
you are the head of gold but
babylon was still there even after
nebuchadnezzar died
so right and this is like another
kingdom will arise after you so it's
like oh we switch from a king to a
kingdom
because they're synonymous yeah and it
does that again in daniel 7 8 where it's
he uses the two synonymously but
if god has a stone kingdom and he is the
stone king
what would it make sense to call the
subjects of his kingdom many stones
yeah we ought to be like just
but he is it's funny he talks about us
as livingston
in the same passage he says you also as
living stones
and see i used to not understand i
thought what a stone what's he talking
about
but he's talking about the the temple is
made of stones
and we occupy placenta we're called like
pillars and everything
we're going to make up that there's a
physical structure but we
make up the temple uh we're the
occupants of the temple
there's a kingdom it's like a government
but then there are the those who live in
the kingdom
there's a temple and there's who live in
the temple so we are stones we're living
stones though not
dead rocks now how does a stone become a
living stone there's a question
stones are alive right how do you become
a living stone fire
i'm fire well actually sort of yeah
i think about how god will change your
heart of stone to the heart of flesh but
that's
yeah is that the other way around well
no it's still not a living stone it's
something living though yeah it turns
out there's a key
it said that the stone was cut out of
the mountain but it also said something
else it was cut out of the mountain
without hands without hands that is
hugely important
because that phrase is used somewhere
else in the bible and then it suddenly
all makes
total sense yeah it's used when when
well i don't know if it's
used there but the same imagery is
on um in exodus when god is
giving the commandments to moses
anything because that's a stone that's
been
it's not cut out with hands it came out
of god that same imagery
so it probably doesn't say it but but
the idea is there i know where it is
that's when jesus died on the cross
and the sanctuary the the veil
yeah he was ripped with with
women yeah it was actually god himself
they did it that's
interesting that is that does relate we
won't talk about today but that is
absolutely true because we can take it a
step further but we won't today
but yes that's very interesting there
but probably the most uh the clearest
the most pertinent
is this in ezekiel it does say a new
heart i'm going to give you
and he says i'm going to give you i'm
going to remove the stony heart
i'm going to give you a heart of flesh
one that's one with my flesh
but ironically we'll have the words that
are written stone on your heart
that's true but notice he says i do it
by my
spirit spirit but the spirit has
something to do without hands as well
i i just go back to that very quick um
because this is this is a verse that
we've actually used quite a few times in
our ministries
um describing when whenever we're kind
of getting to the bottom of the ten
commandments and
and you know the argument really is that
we hear a lot is like oh you legalists
you're
putting all this you know like emphasis
on the ten commandments but but i
really want to point this emphasis out
in this that
it is god's spirit that is put inside of
us and it is
god that makes us walk in his ordinances
and it is
him that helps us to keep the judgments
and to actually do them it is not us
and so even though we we are talking
about the ten commandments and the
importance of it
and the significance of it it still goes
back
all the way to it isn't us we're not the
ones doing this it is literally god's
spirit that's inside of us that's doing
it that's that's
and that's exactly what you see in the
covenant too because the covenant's made
god and abraham they make a covenant
abraham's essentially asleep when god is
fulfilling his end of the bargain so
then the question is well like
well then how does abraham keep the
covenant and if you look at his
descendants break it break it break it
break it break it break it break it
right
until jesus comes as the son of man
right and then he keeps man's end of the
covenant so really it's god on both ends
saying
i know you can't do it i'm going to do
it for you
and there's something so if we if we go
to the things with the wedding mindset
again
we can come to a helpful understanding
legalism is when you're trying to earn
god's favor
climb into heaven if i just do it well
enough i can please him he says that'll
never do it because in your own strength
you can't keep it perfectly there's no
way but
in the wedding relationship he's the
bridegroom we're the
pride but what is a bride called to do
in scripture
be a helper well yeah we are to be a
like a help
meet someone suitable for them that's
true but we're called to
submit as unto the lord i mean it
doesn't mean to do
everything if your husband's telling you
something that's you know filthy or
something
but that is the principle is to submit
we're all part of the bride in relation
to christ
so wait a minute it's not about me
working hard it's about me surrendering
it's like stopping working saying okay
you you take the reins and you do it to
me because i just got it all messed up
now isn't that interesting just that
thought alone in that
that really you know submitting to the
ten commandments where people would be
like you legalist you're working you're
working your way to heaven no i'm i'm
actually letting go
and letting god right and i've shared it
a bunch of times so you guys heard it
over and over but that's how i got freed
from addiction
i was trying in my own strength i'm not
gonna smoke today i'm not gonna drink
today
phil every time and then i finally
reached a point where i was like i can't
do it god you got to take it i give you
permission
take it out of my life i woke up the
next day without a single withdrawal and
i haven't gone back ever since
that was supernatural that's right
incision because that's the word forgive
actually it refers to removal it's not
just like okay it was a boo-boo i won't
pretend it didn't happen he says i'm
happy he's the he's the sin bearer right
he says give it to me i am going to
forgive it i'm going to remove it
put it in the trash dump and you don't
have that in your life anymore
that's when we know we got real
forgiveness
but again that's him it's not us taking
a garbage tub it's just
calling the trash man here please he
says i'm the only too happy to do it
now when i tell people how it happened
for me i say it's all
him you know i tried i failed every time
what are you talking about and the verse
in execution says new spirit
also when jesus is talking with
nicodemus nicodemus
and he said you cannot see new things i
mean you need to be
born with the spirit yes so it's kind of
like i don't know if it's connected
you know what the ten commandments a new
spirit and
and we need to born to be born again
yeah you know through spirit it's
exactly right
yeah so yeah god is going to lead his
bride to become one flesh with him
he's going to lead her to be faithful to
the marriage covenant so i guess you're
going to
try i mean it's just he's he's going to
lead her to do it he gets all
all the credit there now
i said that it was it was cut out
without hands how does the holy spirit
change our hearts it's something he does
to our hearts without hands
and paul says so can you think of an
operation that he does
on our heart i don't know it's an
everlasting covenant
circumcision is that by the heart by the
spirit
right now oh by the way circumcision was
also called the everlasting covenant
but it was on really meant to be on the
heart the other area was a symbol but
this is the real significance of the
harder part but notice this colossians 2
11 you are circumcised with the
circumcision
made without handling there it is right
there whoa
he's saying my kingdom is made up of
people it's done without hands which
means no human intervention
it's not legalism at all right but it's
going to result in a change start in
which the ten commandments are there
that harmonizes all these competing
ideas that people get so mixed up on
it's all him wow that's deep that's
beautiful
that's steve it's interesting yeah we're
just fighting each other with the
with the christian christian dominator
you say like
you're like you know sounds like but
but i think i i i i don't want to hammer
this until
it tells a dead horse but the very idea
that it's like you know no it has
nothing to do with the ten commandments
the ten commandments are nothing it's
like
literally going well that's the covenant
that god gave for his bride you know
what i mean
and everybody wants to throw it out the
window and do whatever you want it
doesn't matter and whatever you do god's
just going to forgive you anyway
every single time you try that in your
marriage you won't be married very long
i think it's ironic that christians will
you know riot in the streets or whatever
don't tear down the ten commandments and
then the same breath oh we don't gotta
keep them
yeah that is interesting that's an
interesting thought yeah
it yeah it is but when you look at the
biblical framework
you don't have these obvious
inconsistencies everything makes perfect
sense yeah
that is something that that is really
beautiful i think i mean that just
really illustrates a
a very foundational deep level of wow
it's still god and his spirit that is
doing that inside of us
there's there's one other thing here
this is the most important thing it's
done without hands
but even when when man was called to do
it as a
symbol before jesus came it says like
here
that zipper used a flint stone to do it
so even there it is all these things
keep coming together is that a
flintstone something that starts a fire
oh fiery stone oh
i know that it's very sharp but yeah
that okay well there we go wow
okay so to put it all together the
foundation of god's kingdom his kingdom
is a stone kingdom
cut out of his mountain mount zion
without hands right
we know that the ten commandments are
engraved by the way not on a rock we
have this idea that you know we see some
sort of rock curling
right no no it's a gemstone right it's a
precious stone one that reflects light
is it beautiful
right so don't don't think of gravel in
your driveway this is wrong it's not a
boulder it's
yeah whatever heavenly sapphire is
infinitely better than our sapphire but
that's a much better approximation of
sapphire
and that original copy was not cut out
with hands man had nothing to do with
those god did it however i wonder you
know
it's like just just a thought you know
there's a pathway that leads out of the
throne of god you know and maybe it's
like
stones or whatever like this can you
just see god like chiseling up
one of the stones and then going i'm
gonna
i'm gonna use this one right here that's
in this pathway
i don't know just a funny thought it's
it's fascinating though so and then he
writes some of the tables of our heart
by the holy spirit who circumcises our
heart
without hands so it just kind of goes
down like this
but then also when you look at jesus
because there's his kingdom
there's his kingdom now look at the king
well let's see
he's the chief cornerstone you know the
foundation of the temple
he circumcises our heart with the
flintstone which is
you know it's amazing hollywood cheapens
things you know we think of some silly
cartoon yeah
no to god flintstone is is something he
uses to say i'm going to rewrite make
your heart it's precious
so he uses the holy spirit there he
removes our stony heart
we become a living stone then we receive
a heart of flesh so that we become
one flesh with him i used to wonder
about that why does he give us a heart
of flesh doesn't paul use flesh in a bad
way
well he does but he's not talking about
that kind here he's saying my nature
that good flesh you know the only good
flesh there is
it results in a marriage a bride who's
faithful to the marriage covenant
which is the ten commandments written in
stone
and so those are the things that i have
seen
to me i just find this just this is awe
inspiring yeah
and i love how you really connected the
dots there so
what is the final conclusion of this
stone that grows into a mountain takes
up the whole
earth it's well it's going to be
the only kingdom that's going to last
forever god's kingdom is going to be on
this earth because the holy city will
will come down on the on the uh the
earth
and he's going to remake it and be in
the new earth it'll be the one that's
gonna last
for ever and it's gonna be made out of
people who have surrendered
every last thing surrendered fully as a
bride who said i
i'm not holding on to one thing you just
take every bit of my heart
they're gonna be filled with this spirit
not you know i've got a little bit of
the
residue the garbage in there it's going
to be totally empty so when you fill
and then it'll be the it's the fiery
beautiful
gemstone kingdom and the whole universe
will be looking on thinking
wow he took something that was so fouled
by sin
and he remade it only god could do this
it'll be like the spectacle for the ages
can i just imagine like a mountain like
you know god's ways are so much higher
than our ways right
have you ever been on the top of a
really really high mountain ever
i climbed mountains really high yeah i
climbed mount shasta in high school i
was about the highest that i'd been
and when you're on there i mean it's
just like
whoa right nobody i think gets to the
top of the mountain and be like
this is terrible right i think everybody
you know is is awed by this just sort of
grand up high view
and it's just like so fitting for god
you know his
his mountain and what's on top of his
mountain and
and you know it's just that statue had
nothing on a mountain
yeah earthly statue and and you're awed
by it and
and you know satan's saying i want to be
you know higher than your mountain i
want to be up here
you know just seems like and he wants us
to walk on the high places of the earth
yeah
yeah so the kingdoms of this earth that
were man-made the gold the
silver the bronze the iron the feet of
iron is just like
i'm going to show you a real kingdom
with and and kingdoms are based on
laws right governments and things like
that right so where
the whole world is going to be on an
eternal government of god's laws
the 10 commandments wow this was deep
yeah i hope you guys enjoyed this i
certainly did
and you know just to just to really
get to the bottom i mean we're not even
scratching the surface actually not even
the bottom
but yeah if you guys want to see more of
this read more of this
here's a book that scott wrote called
the stand and um
a lot of this is taken from this book
right and so
um we'll put a link in the description
below if you have not seen
the other presentation that scott gave
here
on the wedding you got to see this one
to to also get a little depth
into the connection between revelation
and the wedding
and the time that we're living in now so
both those books are available
and if you want to look into this more
we'll put a link in the description
below but
thank you so much for coming on and
blessing us and i think
you're going to have a we're going to
make one of these available for anybody
who wants to
that's right actually we're going to do
a giveaway so
keith tell us a little bit about the
giveaway you just need to go to our
website the link will be in the
description below little lightstudios.tv
free offer and you can go there and
enter to win
one of these books thank you guys for
tuning in
and we will catch you next time
visit our brothers at school for
prophets.tv and watch from babylon to
america which has over 5
million views on youtube alone and
follow it up with america
2 babylon check the description below
for links to this and more
[Music]
foreign